who is Walter Durante Walter Durante was
um you did his voice for the promo
commercial because he was British he was
the New York Times man in Moscow he he
won a Pulitzer uh he got to interview
Stalin which was an enormous
accomplishment for a Westerner
um and while this starvation was this
war in Ukraine uh and it wasn't just
Ukraine of course people were starving
all over the Soviet Union that's where
it was localized I want to be clear
um he was writing the New York Times how
you know people who were saying there's
hunger it's just anti-soviet propaganda
uh this is just and the quote is there
is no famine nor is there likely to be
the Russian people are merely tightening
their belts now that's a very
unfortunate choice of words I'm not
trying to even be humorous you only have
to tighten your belt when you don't have
enough food it's not a fashion Choice it
means your pants are falling off because
you're losing weight and you lose weight
uh in two ways died in exercise which
they weren't doing or lack of caloric
intake and why while this whole thing
was happening you know he's repeatedly
uh talking about how it's the people who
are complaining or just the loudmouths
everyone else is busy doing the work and
putting time in the fields and and
producing so and so forth the Russians
have tightened their belts before
um and when Gareth Jones
who is another who's a British
journalist figured out what was
happening because he got off his train a
stop early and just walked through the
countryside and saw for himself what was
happening the entire Western press Corps
either there's differing accounts
whether this was they sat down and said
dude consciously or they just did it
because they knew what their marching
orders were called him a liar and a
propagandist and so on and so forth and
Durante was the one who took charge of
this whole campaign to smear him as a
complete fraud there was a second one
another British man Malcolm ruggeridge
whose parents were members of the Fabian
Society was a hardcore Lefty uh he got
information as well and then as a result
of this when he kind of leaked the news
of this kind of man-made uh atrocity he
was basically couldn't get work after
that because whether it was because he
had the wrong politics or whether
because he exposed his colleagues as
worse than fools as in League with the
devil
um you know he paid the price but that's
the question Walter Durante wasn't
giving an accurate account of what was
happening inside the Soviet Union as he
later admitted yeah
why what was what was his motivation for
do for I I think it's very hard to get
into the heads of someone who is
putting his name front and center in
terms of denying genocide I mean I have
all the quotes that I'm in the book
where he explicitly said there's no need
for anyone to go to these Villages for a
reporter to tell people you don't need
to go check it out for yourself in a
country which he would clearly admit is
quite secretive is to me unconscionable
I I mean whatever the motivation was it
can't be good uh the best I can think of
that would make the most sense to me is
status right he was the dean of the
Moscow press Corps he was you know the
big shot uh and basically if it's
revealed that he doesn't know what the
hell he's talking about as it was and as
he admitted it's like well then what
good are you so Upton Sinclair has this
quote that's ascribed to him I think he
actually did say this one where he said
it's almost impossible to convince a man
of something when his salary is
dependent on him not being convinced of
it so it might be as simple as that
um yeah I don't know he seemed like a
very
um
I I couldn't work out his motivations I
couldn't work out whether it was
complicity whether he had political
sympathy for what was going on over
there whether it was simply the
associated reflected glory and status
that he was getting from having this
sort of access to people that no Western
journalists would or should do and
perhaps a blend of all of them I suppose
one of the other things that happened
obviously Downstream from or maybe there
was also a theory that he was being
blackmailed to some extent so that could
that would make some sense that the
Russians had some Intel on him and they
didn't want it revealed who knows that's
interesting
one of the other things that happened
Downstream from there being widespread
famine and so actually going back to the
famine for a second
if the use of the famine from Stalin was
to
beat and erode the Ukrainian spirit
surely they could have considered we
might just kill them all it might end up
as having no people left in the Ukraine
to conquer
well I I mean they killed they sure
killed a lot of them but I think it was
I don't that's a good question
I wonder if that was a concern
I guess because they were given some
grain it's not like they were given
literally none right they took it all
but they gave some back yes
so what happens Downstream from a famine
next thing that happens is you have uh
an ever increasing paranoia within the
people who are in charge of what's going
on
uh among the populace and this I mean
there's a story where is it Stalin who's
who gives the
the police
and a quota for each different area
he I need 10 000 criminals from this
region in this region in this region in
this region which kind of like the kids
from earlier on drive around and tell us
who your accomplices are caused the law
enforcement to go around they were
retrofitting the number of criminals to
their quota for criminals as opposed to
catching people that were doing crime
yeah this is something that I think
again westerners have a hard time
wrapping their heads around and even I
have a hard time wrapping my head around
um Stalin would sit down
and you have a piece of paper and he'd
be like all right in Kazakhstan you need
to arrest 50 000 people or whatever the
number is in you know in Saint
Petersburg or Leningrad you need to rest
10 000 in leviv you need to rest this
many and it was the job of the uh nkvd
or the KGB whatever it was at the time
to be like all right this is how many
people we have to find and his last of
the uh secret police heads barrier is
most known for his quote uh show me the
man I'll show you the crime and they
prided themselves on getting confessions
out of people who were perfectly
innocent and the argument is well if we
arrested you you must have done
something and if you're saying that
we're arresting innocent people that in
and of itself is being
counter-revolutionary and criticizing
the government so that in itself is a
crime so yeah and I my understanding is
these lists are still in like the
archives in the Kremlin like they still
have them this isn't just like hearsay
like they have the piece of paper where
he's got the names of the different
places and the members what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full
witted episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]